laser acne scar removal near me okay so
he's taking care of his skin green flag
Omakase Sushi New York City
okay great fantastic do you like sushi
yeah who doesn't like that's a great
first date right great first date Max
got his credit card yeah yeah
U.S shoe size to French does that mean
he likes to travel or he's from France
Kanye Pete Davidson memes it shows that
he's like funny I think this guy seems
more wealthy
laser acne that's like expensive it's
like 50 bucks 70
speak Easy's New York City okay so he
likes to go out get hammered black out I
feel like this guy probably wait I feel
like sneak easy is kind of like a classy
box oh it's classy yeah Louis Vuitton
men's what does rtw stand for 2022. he's
so into fashion he's into fashion wait
he definitely has a good sense of style
maybe he's from Europe yeah I'm from
Pittsburgh